feeling you i am angry angry  angry and upset  the united states congress can keep  rovers display the law of land they just  need to do it i've never seen you so  angry you seem to be this is what  the republicans have been working toward  this day  for decades they have been out there  plotting  carefully cultivating these supreme  court justices  so they could have a majority on the  bench who would accomplish something  that the majority of americans do not  want 69 percent of people across this  country  across this country red states and blue  states old people and young people want  i don't care what type of leader you are  the fact that you as a leader